blanc fait vous ne savez pas comment
votre fils est mort vous devez enquêter
sur tout et vous confronter finalement
ils étaient ni sur la liste des morts
nés sur l'île d'eubée sexualité
hopitalisés il était nulle part est ce
qu'on peut vivre malgré cette douleur
quand j'ai écrit à la fois je souffrais
parce que ça me rappelait des beaux
souvenirs avec stéphane et en même temps
c'était très douloureux et puis
aujourd'hui je me suis aperçu que ça
permettait d'extraire de de moi même
toute cette histoire est donc ça m'a
apporté un peu de recul un peu
d'apaisement mais la douleur est la
couleur seront là jusqu'à ma mort
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes ensemble
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
jusqu'à 21h30 pour décrypter les grands
titres de l'actualité de la journée au
sommaire de ce mercredi 12 janvier à la
une de la réunion otan-russie
aujourd'hui à bruxelles quatre heures
quasiment de négociation pour au final
rester dans une impasse sur la question
et craignent haine et la sécurité en
europe des différences majeures avec
moscou et l'otan reste ouverte au
dialogue la dernière en demain à vienne
avec cette fois-ci l'organisation pour
la sécurité et la coopération en europe
alors at-on des chances de sortir de
l'impasse quels sont les enjeux pour les
occidentaux et pour la russie on ouvre
ce dossier complexe en quelques instants
boston a bien participé à une fête
pendant le confinement au royaume uni
une garden party en mai 2020 alors que
les rassemblements était pourtant
interdite le premier ministre
britannique a présenté ses excuses
aujourd'hui devant les députés il a
expliqué qu'il pensait être à une
réunion de travail un énième scandale
qui ne passent par chez l'opposition qui
réclame haut et fort sa démission
la lutte anti corrida en france et le
sénat qui poursuit ce soir l'examen du
projet de loi qui transforme le passé ni
terre en passe vaccinale plus d'une
centaine d'amendements sion débattue en
ce moment les sénateurs ont voté une
mesure prévoyant l'extinction
automatique du dispositif en dessous
d'un certain seuil d'hospitalisation des
modifications majeures contre l'avis du
gouvernement
et autres changements importants le
sénat qui refusent que les cafetiers
restaurateurs effectué des vérifications
d'identité des patrons soulagé puisqu'il
doit déjà demandé les passes sanitaires
à tous leurs clients une mesure bien
lourde qui a fait baisser la
fréquentation selon certains
établissements dans notre rubrique qu'en
pensent les français nous irons
justement la rencontre d'un restaurateur
parisien très inquiet pour l'avenir de
son restaurant alors les petits patrons
grandes victimes de la crise du coc vide
on attend vos réactions sur le compte au
telegraph verte et france
[Musique]
après quasiment quatre heures de
négociations l'otan et la russie n'ont
donc pas réussi à trouver un terrain
d'entente aujourd'hui des négociations à
bruxelles jugé crucial qui coince
toujours sur la question de l'extension
de l'otan et la crise ukrainienne on
retrouve notre correspondante à moscou
maëlys d'estrées bonsoir maylis une
dernière rencontre donc prévu pour le
même demain viennent mais aujourd'hui
une chose est sûre tout est resté bloqué
bonsoir stéphanie effectivement à
l'instar de la rencontre russo
américaines organisé ce lundi à genève
pas de réelles avancées lors du conseil
otan russie d'aujourd'hui et des accords
qui oppose les deux parties sont telles
que celles ci reconnaissent elles-mêmes
ne pas encore savoir comment les
résoudre les tensions restent très
fortes entre la russie et l'occident
washington et ses alliés craignent une
invasion de l'ukraine par moscou en
raison de mouvements de troupes russes à
la frontière russo ukrainienne la russie
tout en démentant fermement une telle
intention exigent des garanties que
l'otan ne s'élargit rapin vers l'est et
ne déploiera pas de missiles près de ses
frontières lors d'une conférence de
presse à l'issue du conseil otan russie
le vice ministre russe des affaires
étrangères a reproché à l'alliance
atlantique de chercher à atteindre la
supériorité dans tous les domaines et
dans tous les théâtres d'opérations
militaires écoutez
donc la discussion d'aujourd'hui était
ouverte direct approfondie riche mais en
même temps cette discussion a mis au
jour un certain nombre de divergences
sur des questions fondamentales
et une de ces question principale c'est
que l'otan
considère le principe d'indivisibilité
de
la sécurité de façon tout à fait
alternative de façon tout à fait
sélective est il comme je lé deal ne
prennent pas en compte les intérêts de
sécurité des autres pays
et pour nos l'indivisibilité de la
sécurité doit concerner tout le monde
où la sécurité ne doit pas se faire
contre la russie et ce en la contournant
sinon elle est vouée à l'échec
et si l'otan passe à une politique de
dissuasion ça veut dire que ce sera une
politique pour nous deux contres
dissuasion et une politique
d'intimidation nous réagirons de la même
façon et si elle le système des défenses
qui sont mis en place contre là aussi ça
veut dire que nous chercherons aussi ce
n'est pas notre choix mais en tout cas
si nous ne parvenons pas à
modifier l'évolution actuelle
de son côté le secrétaire général de
l'otan a également souligné cette
divergence entre la russie et l'alliance
qui selon lui seront difficiles à
surmonter il voit toutefois un signal
positif dans le fait qu'un dialogue ait
eu lieu aujourd'hui au caire
cette discussion n'a pas été facile mais
c'est exactement la raison pour laquelle
elle était si importante
les alliés de l'otan sur incident sur
les perspectives de progrès de ces
pourparlers et ans
ils se sont déclarés gravement préoccupé
par le renforcement des forces
militaires russes en ukraine et dans ses
environs et ont appelé moscou à
désamorcer immédiatement la situation
ainsi qu'à respecter la souveraineté et
l'intégrité territoriale de ses voisins
ils ont également appelé la russie à
s'abstenir de tout coup sûr de force
agressive et de toutes activités
malveillantes à l'encontre des alliés et
à respecter l'ensemble de ses
obligations et engagements
internationaux
et
cela signifie que notre dialogue tout
cela signifie que notre dialogue est
difficile il est plus que jamais
nécessaire
les alliés de l'otan ont souligné qu'ils
ne les ménagera aucun effort pour
trouver une issue politique
du côté américain la secrétaire d'état
adjointe wendy sherman a déclaré colotte
l'otan ne renoncerait pas à sa politique
de portes ouvertes mais que cela
n'empêchait pas la russie et l'alliance
atlantique de coopérer dans certains
domaines une chose est sûre en tout cas
la russie et l'occident comptent
poursuivre leur dialogue via les canaux
diplomatiques et militaires les
pourparlers entre représentants russes
européens et américains se poursuivront
dès ce jeudi cette fois ci à vienne dans
le cadre de l'organisation pour la
sécurité et la coopération en europe il
suivra évidemment merci aux malices
destrait en direct de moscou alors
attend encore une chance de trouver une
issue dans cette crise ukrainienne avec
notamment ces négociations demain
viennent au delà des déclarations des
uns et des autres quel enjeu au centre
de ces échanges occident russie c'est
l'heure de notre décryptage avec nos
invités
[Musique]
avec nous pour en parler sur ce plateau
tout d'abord général de minutes
trinquant bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
un expert en géostratégie à nos côtés
également direct par skype régis le
sommier grand reporter rt france ainsi
que nicolas mirkovic analyste politique
bonsoir à tous les deux merci d'être
avec nous alors on le voit le général
trinquons les rendez vous diplomatiques
qui s'enchaînent qui ne se ressemblent
pas nécessairement mais quand même pour
trouver un accord et la situation qui
semble bloquée malgré les déclarations
de bonnes intentions excepté quand même
ce constat de divergence fondamentale
avec l'otan selon les les russes on peut
parler d'un dialogue de sourds entre
l'otan et la russie alors le premier
point c'est qu'on peut parler de
dialogue rappelle que le dialogue otan
russie avaient été suspendus il y a deux
ans et demi les russes décidant qu'il
n'y avait plus de dialogue à avoir avec
le temps et donc il est heureux
qu'aujourd'hui ce dialogue ait lieu
alors quand on s'est tu pendant deux ans
et demi évidemment ça prend on va
prendre un peu de temps pour se mettre
d'accord pour progresser 1 le dialogue
c'est toujours des des concessions de
part et d'autre bon ben je pense que le
premier round c'est simplement de
mesurer quelle est la position de chacun
des interlocuteurs alors les positions à
sont assez claires en tout cas du côté
de la russie à cette ligne rouge
évidemment à la politique de portes
ouvertes de de l'otan moscou la jugent
comme clairement une menace pour sa
sécurité
nicolas miskovic c'est légitime tout de
même de de vouloir empêcher des
activités militaires proches de la
frontière russe je pense que la russie a
clairement montré donc sa ligne rouge et
la russie est dans son droit n'oublions
pas que ce sont les soldats les armées
de l'otan qui depuis des années ne cesse
de mener des actions exercices
militaires le long de la frontière russe
que ce sont ces le camp atlantiste c'est
washington qui clairement clairement à
organiser forme et pousser à des
sédition et des révolutions de couleur
en ukraine en géorgie en arménie c'est
vers cela frontières russes bout d'un
moment il est légitime qu'une nation
souveraine disent qu'ils ne veulent plus
qu'une organisation étrangère vienne l'a
titillé l'excité la provoquer sur ses
propres frontières c'est tout à fait
légitime et je pense qu'en définition
cette liste de
comment garder que la russie veut
négocier avec avec washington la russie
montre que la nuit rouge a clairement
été franchi et qu'il est temps de se
mettre à la table des négociations sinon
un incident grave va arriver la
diplomatie russe ne s'en est pas caché
lors de notre côté c'est vrai qu'on
ne reproche le jeu aux russes de
s'attaquer à la souveraineté évidemment
de de l'ukraine c'est vrai que régis le
sommier pour rebondir sur ce que disait
nicolas mirkovic on se souvient qu'au
lendemain de du chute du mur de berlin
les américains avaient vraiment promis à
la russie de ne surtout pas étendre
l'otan s'étaient déjà à l'époque la
ligne rouge il ya ce sentiment
effectivement de trahison de confiance
rompue que ressent vladimir poutine
aujourd'hui s'attend cette question
oui tout d'abord il ya une dizaine de
pays en gros de dexter up de l'est qui
ont rejoint ou l'otan ou comment l'eau
de l'union européenne donc c'est sûr que
la russie a tendance quand on voit de
son point de vue de voir justement le
monde occidental s'approcher de ses
frontières et aujourd'hui on arrive
aucun ultime puisque à la fois sur la
question de la géorgie et la question de
l'ukraine il y à un risque pour la
russie que ces deux pays décident enfin
décide ou en tout cas ce oasis de
rejoindre l'organisation du traité de
l'atlantique nord et ça c'est pour les
russes on l'a dit on va on va pas
revenir là dessus éternellement mais
c'est quelque chose qui est
insupportable qui n'est pas peut pas de
l'ordre du possible maintenant sur la
situation en effet elle les critiques en
effet il y a de part et d'autre des
forces mobilisées 1 dans les pays baltes
par exemple vous avez des forces
françaises à l'heure actuelle faut le
savoir l'opinion publique française ne
l'est pas n'est pas forcément informés
de ça mais en tout cas la france
participe et d'autres pays à des
manoeuvres aussi et de l'autre côté la
russie et bien la situation ont dit oui
les chars sont massés à or aux
frontières regardant les choses dans
leur réalité depuis 2014 il y à environ
70 milles troupes russes qui sont sur la
frontière ukrainienne il y a l'est de
l'ukraine des commandes et des tranchées
avec eux on est dans un état quasiment
de guerre et deux fois par an en gros en
russie il y à des manoeuvres militaires
qui monte qui font monter ce nombre de
soldats de 70 à 100 milles environ
massés aux frontières actuellement la
question c'est qu'une partie de l'armée
ukrainienne a été renforcée je les ai
déjà dit sur cette antenne mais par des
missiles antichars par des drones par
des à des équipements plus modernes et
que la russie elle attend dé s'adapte en
protégeant ses chars donc il ya eu une
escalade technologique on dirait qu'ils
existent mais en tout cas pour ce qui
est des manoeuvres des uns et des autres
c'est quand même quelque chose qui
existe depuis des mines 2014 et depuis
le début de la crise ukrainienne puisque
je rappelle les accords de minsk n'ont
jamais étaient appliquées le
gouvernement de kiev n'a jamais négocié
avec les républiques de l'est de
l'ukraine et ce qui était prévu dans le
cadre de commandes de ces accords et
désaccords n'ont en réalité jamais été
appliquée donc cette situation de guerre
larvée elle existe depuis un moment à la
frontière avec sonia et on voit que la
confiance est évidemment arts a du mal à
se faire entre les deux camps si j'ose
dire washington donc on le disait
inquiet que je moscou de vouloir envahir
l'ukraine malgré de multiples démentis
que peu que devrait faire général
trinquant moscou pour convaincre les
occidentaux d' de sa bonne foi
la première chose serait de ne pas
dramatiser quand j'entends les pays de
l'est ce qu'on appelait les pays de
l'est autrefois qui ont rejoint l'europe
et l'otan je voudrais rappeler
simplement que ces pays étaient des pays
occupés par l'union soviétique autres
temps autres moeurs si j'ose dire on
n'est plus tout à fait dans cette
configuration on ait pu face à l'union
soviétique mais avec la russie qui doit
dialoguer avec les européens aujourd'hui
on voit bien que dans le dialogue on
parlait de l'accord de minsk tout à
l'heure c'est le format qu'on appelait
format normandie or qui était en pointe
de de discussions avec la russie c'était
l'allemagne et la france or là monsieur
poutine a réussi son coup si j'ose dire
c'est je suis un grand jeu discutent
directement avec monsieur biden est
directement avec les états unis donc je
crois qu'il faut revenir à la réalité
des choses nous n'avons pu de l'autre
côté une d'un côté une idéologie qui
était l'idéologie soviétique qui
occupaient des pays européens mais des
pieds au point un terrain qu'ils ont
librement choisi avec des élections avec
des votes de rejoindre l'europe alors
aujourd'hui la question se pose
essentiellement en ukraine où il ya une
conflagration en ukraine est
effectivement là il ya des tensions très
importante avec d'une part des forces
russes importante à la frontière et de
l'autre côté un soutien apporté à
l'ukraine puisque l'ukraine aujourd'hui
dit qu'elle elle veut régler le problème
donc il faut revenir un petit peu comme
cela a été cité à l'accord la corde
minsk et que kiev n'a pas appliqué je
suis d'accord également et il faut
revenir en abaissant les tensions et en
ne refusant pas le jeu des empires
s'affrontant si je veux dire ça n'est
plus de l'époque nicolas amicaux vite ya
aussi eu cet aspect aujourd'hui devant
les opinions respectives de dd président
de ne pas peut-être s'abaisser à
dialoguer c'est peut-être le cas de joe
biden on en a déjà parlé d'ailleurs
lundi c'est une forme de faiblesse de
négocier avec le président russe en tout
cas pour les démocrates et dans
l'opinion américaine
je pense que ce jeu de type de
négociation se fait dans le temps ce
sont les négociations extrêmement
importante et c'est normal qu'à ce stade
là on va rentrer au premier rang
hebeisen et poutine qui sont déjà
rencontrés en juin dernier à genève il y
avait déjà une porte était ouverte au
dialogue là ce ne sont pas des surhommes
coup tout ce sont des techniciens des
spécialistes qui vont se retrouver dans
les différentes réunions qui sont
organisées cette semaine je pense que
c'est pas une forme de faiblesse même si
on l'a vu que côte est des états unis
pour la première fois et commence à
invoquer des menaces ou des sanctions
directement entre vladimir poutine je ne
savais pas du tout l'esprit de ces
discussions là hop techniquement les
attentistes vont regarder les
propositions russes y ont discuté vont
dialoguer c'est tout à fait normal à ce
stade là à des discussions il n'y a pas
d'autres interprétations costa avoir
alors effectivement gsee le sommières
les menacent de lourdes pénalités
économiques un des nouvelles
implantations sur ces négociations
on parle de sanction inédite évidemment
ça va souvent débattu ici de leur
efficacité je me propose d'ailleurs de
regarder cette carte 1 quand on sait que
la russie au loyer sur cette carte
exporte donc avec 40% de son gaz en
europe on peut se poser la question
finalement 2 qui serait le plus perdant
est ce que de ce point de vue là
l'europe est un petit peu coincé tout de
même
alors l'europe malheureusement ne
comment on n'a pas tellement voix au
chapitre alors elle est consultée mais
comme le disait le général traquant tout
à l'heure les admire poutine est ravi de
parler directement et de ne plus
inscrire justement dans dans ces formats
de dialogue avec la france et
l'allemagne la question du gaz et la
question énergétique et la question
aussi des sanctions parce que la russie
est sous l'objet de sanctions c'est que
aujourd'hui l'europe est
particulièrement l'allemagne
fragilité vis-à-vis de la russie avec la
russie avec l'accord comment avec le
gazoduc north stream n'est plus
contrainte de faire passer son gaz par
l'ukraine et ce gaz arrive directement
en allemagne il y a eu d'ailleurs des
légères interruption de gaz comment
comme un petit peu un signal de moscou
qu'on pourrait couper les robinets et si
on coupe les robinets en plein hiver en
allemagne est particulièrement dans la
dans la partie orientale de l'allemagne
vient c'est des milliers ni millions de
personnes qui peuvent se retrouver sans
chauffage et ça c'est un c'est un vrai
problème parce qu'ils aient donc il ya
deux gazoducs aya nord stream et nord
stream 2 et sa d'une salle certains
dassin pas une certaine façon
l'allemagne est particulièrement comment
est ce dire est
vulnérable vis-à-vis de de commandes la
russie alors il faut savoir aussi une
chose c'est que on l'a vu depuis un
petit moment
l'administration byden ne considère
comme en europe qu'un seul interlocuteur
l'allemagne et la russie de son côté est
également considère l'allemagne est
assez peu les autres acteurs on en est
malheureusement nous français même les
anglais comment et les italiens encore
plus à faire de la figuration dans cette
espèce de gigantesque bras de fer qui
est en train de se jouer à l'est et on a
vu en effet que d'un côté donc va
l'admirent poutine dialogue directement
avec le président américain et de
l'autre côté aussi il faut prendre en
compte que joe biden a une très mauvaise
cote dans son opinion publique
aujourd'hui que les élections de mi
mandat sont en train d'arriver et que
qu'il risque de les perdre donc la
tentation comme tout président américain
qui arrive aux élections de mi mandat
c'est justement d'agiter le a6 fond
d'une menace internationale et là ça
tombe à pic pour baden pour montrer que
il est capable de montrer ses muscles
parce que n'oublions pas que byden paye
encore aujourd'hui dans l'opinion
publique américaine le retrait
désastreux d'afghanistan et que les
républicains sont décidés justement à ne
pas lui faire oublier hayden a intérêt à
montrer aussi que vis-à-vis de poutine
et vis-à-vis des russes il a un discours
ferme donc on est sur un mélange à la
fois effectivement de données comme vous
l'avez dit économique qui pèse dans ces
négociations
mais il ne faut pas oublier la question
des opinions publiques nationales et la
question de la réalité des agendas
électoraux au moment où on parle et où
résiste sommier d'ailleurs nous disait
que les français l'europe et en
particuliers notamment les français
n'ont pas vraiment voix au chapitre on
apprend à l'instant que par une dépêche
que jean yves le drian déclarent
préférer une stratégie de détente plutôt
qu'un bras de fer avec la russie ça dit
quoi ça on a connu jean yves le drian
plus voilà plus hostiles aux russes et
on n'a pas le choix aujourd'hui il faut
être pragmatique il faut être
pragmatique et de toutes façons il n'y a
que le dialogue qui paiera je ne crois
absolument pas à des divisions russe qui
vont aller vers kiev je n'y crois
absolument pas donc il s'agit de
détendre et il s'agit de discuter la
discussion autour aujourd hui
d'aujourd'hui pardon et et otan russie
demain celle au fce lots et c est un
format beaucoup plus large et c'est la
sécurité en europe complètement qu'il
faut reprendre en compte parce que
effectivement on peut comprendre d'une
côté les anciens pays dont je rappelle
toujours qu'ils étaient occupés par
l'union soviétique qui aujourd'hui ont
peur de ce qu'on appelle l'ours russe et
les français qui ont toujours eu
tendance à vouloir dialoguer avec la
russie et vous amener les gens à ce
dialogue et c'est vrai que ce qui vient
d'être appelé est très juste il faut
voir aussi les problèmes intérieurs
l'allemagne vient d'avoir des élections
elle a ses problèmes d'énergie et
monsieur bart hayden lui s'annonce vers
des élections qui risquent d'être
catastrophiques pour lui pas
catastrophique au sens où il risque de
perdre la majorité et donc tous ces
éléments doivent être pris en compte et
c'est pour ça que je parle de ce
dialogue il est dommage qu'il ait été
arrêté pendant deux ans et demi parce
qu'on a beaucoup de mal à le reprendre
après deux ans et demi de silence mais
il est temps de le faire nicholas
markowitz dans votre point de vue quelle
est aujourd'hui l'issue effectivement la
plus probable dans dans cette crise
qu'elle est en tout cas vous votre
lecture
je pense que ce qui est déjà bien c'est
que le fait que cette porte dans le
dialogue qui a été ouverte déjà depuis
l'été dernier qui va se poursuivre ce
problème ne va pas se régler du jour au
lendemain on sait que la russie a
demandé une réponse à l'otan avoir un
son premier fils d'un prochain sommet au
mois de juin prochain j'espère que ça va
aller vite je pense que c'est assez
important que le monde que le monde
occidental comprennent que les russes
n'en peuvent plus des sanctions injustes
de la part des états unis les sanctions
qui ruine les sanctions européennes qui
ruinent avant tout les agriculteurs les
entreprises européennes qui ne peuvent
plus exporter sur le marché russe les
russes depuis longtemps ont compris que
s'il ne pouvait pas faire plus faire
affaire avec les uns avec les européens
de l'ouest gaz et les faire affaire avec
d'autres sites d'autres pays voire même
lancé leurs propres économies mais
qu'ils veulent avant tout être ce qu'ils
ont toujours été c'est à dire une
puissance européenne le l'exemple du
gazoduc north stream 2 est un exemple
parfait c'est un projet 100% européen
entre russes et d'autres sociétés
européennes et qu'est-ce qui vous qu'est
ce qui bloque ce projet ce sont les
états unis donc du coup je pense que la
russie a montré que c'était fini qu'elle
n'avait plus encaissé les coups comme
bout d'un moment il était temps que
réaliste qu'elle montre que la ligne
rouge était non seulement proche mais
cohabiter franchir mais qu'elle était
prête maintenant à se défendre avec les
mêmes elles et avec les moyens qu'il a
définie a qui sont ou peuvent être aux
militaires ou alternative parce que du
coup on a trop joué avec la russie et je
pense que ce qui est important c'est que
cela réveille un petit peu les nations
européennes qui se rend compte qu'elles
sont le dindon de la farce dans ces
négociations puisque il n'y a en effet
pas d'une nation européenne présents
dans ce dialogue entre la la ce sur des
crises qui concerne les états unis et ou
qui concerne pardon des pays européens
washington est à plus de dix mille
kilomètres des républiques du nom basse
ont du coup on et j'espère quand même
que certaines nations européennes vont
se rendre compte qu'il est temps
qu'elles rentrent dans la négociation
qu'ils puissent exprimer leur voix et
que les pays européens trouvent une
issue entre elles elles n'ont pas besoin
de l'aide de washington ni des états
unis voilà régis le sommier justement
sur ces propos nicolas
mirko vide qui dit en substance la rue
s'il tend vers vers l'europe parce que
ce n'est pas cela le fond de la question
la russie qui a tout simplement envie
d'être reconnus respectés
a à peine at et des réalités si j'ose
dire moi je vais pas vous dire le
contraire j'ai toujours prôné justement
un rapprochement notamment
la russie non mais je pense que je pense
qu'il ya matière à rapprochement je
parle pas d'ailleurs uniquement de la
russie je pense que vis-à-vis de la
turquie également on ne peut pas laisser
aux périphérie de l'europe parce que ça
nous concerne directement des pays qui
ont des comportements où il existe des
tensions il faut absolument dialoguer
avec ces pays il faut absolument
reprendre langue avec eux la question de
l'ukraine doit être résolue d'une façon
ou d'une autre on le sent bien les etats
unis sont attachés à la souveraineté de
l'ukraine ça a l'air d'être très
important pour eux et d'un autre côté la
russe la russie ne veut absolument pas
de l'otan à ses frontières il faut je
pense qu'on peut trouver dans cette note
dans ce cadre une forme de je vais dire
de finlandisation de l'ukraine et de la
géorgie savez la finlande était restée
une sorte de pays neutre entre l'est et
l'ouest à l'issue de la première guerre
mondiale de la deuxième guerre mondiale
pardon et il se faut que là il faut que
les petits deux points de vue d'une
certaine façon soit respectée et que les
européens aussi fassent un effort pour
parler d'une même voix parce que là on
sent à chaque fois qu'il y à des
tensions ou des des manières différentes
de voir la situation est aujourd'hui on
est revenu à un dialogue comme je le
disais tout à l'heure entre byden et
poutine entre russes et américains et ça
n'est pas nécessairement dans nos
intérêts ça n'est pas dans les intérêts
de la france et la france peut-être à
une carte à jouer ou à des cartes
différentes à jouer aujourd'hui d'autant
que la france reste un pays respecté
avec une arme est formidable et des
intérêts dans le monde il faut qu'elle
fasse entendre le savoir en dehors
c'est mauvais bout de de vous répondre
oui non temps vous êtes moins ne pas lui
couper la parole à je voudrais
simplement rappeler que le dialogue
entre la russie et les européens c'est
monsieur poutine qui l'a bail passé
c'est monsieur poutine qui a voulu
discuter avec les américains directement
pour se placer au niveau des grands et
donc à évacuer le dise que la discussion
avec les européens ça c'est le premier
point le deuxième point quant à la
géorgie et l'ukraine je voudrais
rappeler qu'il y a des années que la
georgie et l'ukraine ont demandé à
rejoindre le temps et c'est l'allemagne
et la france qui ont mis leur veto et
qui ont dit non parce qu'il savait que
c'était trop dangereux donc je crois que
tout le monde a raison il faut que les
européens reviennent dans cette
discussion mais encore faudrait-il que
monsieur poutine le veut le veuille
aujourd'hui pour son opinion nationale
il est bien plus j'ai à dire en posture
il est bien plus satisfait de discuter
directement avec les états unis merci
régis repartez pas pour deux pour 15
minutes à les y met vraiment vital par
des mots bien quand même deux choses
très différentes je suis d'accord avec
le l'analyse du général traquant ya
quand même deux choses différentes qui
se sont produites ces derniers temps et
je pense que vous ne pouvez pas les
ignorer c'est le double départ des
américains d'afghanistan web été décrété
et qui est fait sans consultation des
alliés et puis cette fameuse affaire de
sous marins australiens où on se passe
de nous demander notre avis donc le
problème avec les américains aujourd'hui
c'est qu'on veut bien dialoguer mais on
veut bien avoir des alliés mais encore
faudrait-il qu entre alliés on se parle
et qu'on arrête de se comporter de cette
façon là merci en tout cas à tous les
trois régis le sommier nicolas mirkovic
heure gérald raccord merci d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur arte france
et direction présent les états unis on
s'intéresse ce soir à la création d'une
unité consacrée à la lutte contre le
terrorisme intérieur les autorités
disent redouter une hausse d idéologie
anti gouvernementales elles veulent
cibler les personnes susceptibles de
passer à l'acte on retrouve tout de
suite notre corps est ce qu'on antheaume
abonnés en direct de washington
bonsoir thomas l'annoncent don de cette
formation de ce groupe de lutte
antiterroriste était faite hier au sénat
américain
oui les autorités officiellement
s'inquiète de la hausse des menaces
émanant de la population américaine le
directeur national de la lutte
antiterroriste matt olsen explique qu'il
était nécessaire d'avoir une unité
spécialement dédié à ces faits selon ces
données le nombre d' enquête du fbi sur
des suspects soupçonnés de faits de
terrorisme intérieur a plus que doublé
depuis le printemps 2020 alors il ya
quand même cette question qu'est ce qui
est véritablement qualifié de terrorisme
intérieur et bien toujours selon amath
olsen la menace concerne surtout des
individus exprimant des animosités
raciale voire même des personnes qui
rejettent l'idée même d'autorité il ya
aussi un autre cas de figure une
question lui a été posée par une
sénatrice est-ce que les événements au
capitole le 6 janvier 2021 peuvent être
considérés comme du terrorisme intérieur
écoutez sa réponse
le département de justice et le fbi ayew
était clair les attaques les événements
qui se sont déroulés le 6 janvier sont
en cours d'investigation
en tant que terrorisme intérieur les
femmes pour citer la définition du
terrorisme intérieur par le code fédéral
cela implique des actes dangereux pour
la vie humaine qui sont une violation de
la loi et qui ont pour but d'influencer
la politique du gouvernement par
l'intimidation la contrainte je pense
donc qu'il est parfaitement appropriée
car les événements du 6 janvier soit
considérée dans l' enquête comme des
actes de terrorisme intérieur
alors il convient tout de même de
rappeler que sur les plus de 700
personnes qui ont été arrêtées à la
suite des événements au capitole le 6
janvier 2021 aucune poursuite pour des
motifs d'insurrection pour tout autre
fait est liée à du terrorisme intérieur
est en réalité la définition même de
terrorisme intérieur semble quelque peu
galvaudé il y avait aussi l'exemple de
ses parents d'élèves qui avait eu le
tort de faire part de leurs
préoccupations sur le contenu des
programmes scolaires enseigner à leurs
enfants et bien une association de
comités directeurs d'établissements
scolaires avaient adressé une lettre à
joe biden pour lui demander de
poursuivre ses parents d'élèves là
encore pour des faits de terrorisme
intérieur il ya même eu des enquêtes
diligentées en ce sens par le ministère
de la justice on comprendre bien donc
qu'au delà des véritables enjeux de
sécurité nationale il ya aussi
certainement une volonté du gouvernement
américain de maintenir dans l'espace
public l'existence de cette menace qui
émaneront l'a bien compris de groupes
présentés comme d'extrême droite voire
de suprémacistes blancs alors pour une
partie des républicains il s'agit d'une
manoeuvre inquiétante une manoeuvre
politicienne par ce qu'ils expliquent
qu'en plus le gouvernement de joe biden
focalise l'attention sur ces mouvements
qualifiés donc à d'extrême droite et
omet les violences et les menaces qui
émane de l'autre côté de l'échiquier
politique merci thomas bonnin en direct
de washington
on poursuit avec l'actualité
internationale nous évoquons la
situation à hong kong où une série de
nouvelles infractions à la sécurité
nationale vient d'être décidé nous
verrons dans quelques instants quelle
est la portée de ses décisions avec vous
ou claude blanche raisons qui nous a
rejoints sur ce plateau bonsoir et à
tout à l'heure on va aussi sur la bordée
ensemble l'une des grosses actualités
internationales de la journée on a
beaucoup parlé ici ou là au royaume uni
ce scandale sur boris johnson dont on
vous parlait déjà hier et bien il ya la
suite aujourd'hui puisque le premier
ministre britannique a bien reconnu
avoir participé à une fête pendant le
confinement il a d'ailleurs présenté ses
excuses le récit de rémy savary
monsieur le président je tiens à
m'excuser la fête semble finie pour
boris johnson dans la tourmente après
les révélations d'une nouvelle fête
clandestine le premier ministre
britannique a dû faire face aux députés
je sais que des millions de personnes à
travers ce pays ont fait des sacrifices
extraordinaires au cours des 18 derniers
mois je connais l'angoissent qu'elles
ont traversé incapable de faire le deuil
de leurs proches incapable de vivre leur
vie comme elle le souhaite ou de faire
les choses qu'elle aime et je sais la
rage qu'elles ressentent à mon égard et
à l'égard du gouvernement que je dirige
lorsqu'elle pense à downing street même
les règles ne sont pas correctement
suivis par ceux qui font les règles
à mort ping propres les fonds elle
paraît depuis pourvue myfab autre face à
une chambre des communes qui demandaient
des explications beau joe a affirmé
prendre la responsabilité des erreurs
qui ont été commises mais l'opposition
demande elle bien davantage après des
mois de tromperie et mensonges
cet homme pathétique n'a plus nulle part
où se cacher
sa défense qui consiste à dire qu'il ne
savait pas qu'il était à une fête
c'est tellement ridicule que c'est en
fait insultant pour l'opinion publique
britannique
il a finalement été forcé d'admettre ce
que tout le monde savait que lorsque
tout le pays étaient confinés ils
organisaient des soirées arrosées à
downing street ici doit-il maintenant la
décence de démissionner
un départ également demandé par les
indépendantistes du snpi et par les
libéraux démocrates après ses excuses au
parlement boris johnson trouve encore
des excuses invoquant une réunion de
travail mais lors de ce rassemblement le
royaume-uni est en plein dans la
première vague de kovy 19 et les règles
sont strictes les rassemblements de plus
de deux personnes en extérieur sont
interdits or une centaine de convives
auraient été invités à cette garden
party si l'avenir semble s'assombrir
pour boris johnson à la tête du
gouvernement britannique
l'actuel locataire du 10 downing street
est encore bien loin d'un départ est-ce
que son propre parti va dire désolé on
n'est plus crédible et c'est à cause de
vous donc il faut partir ou non et il ya
des chances que ils disent non et qu'ils
y pensent que les supporteurs de boris
eltsine vont le soutenir encore et qu'il
va rester en place c'est comme tout en
angleterre maintenant tout est divisée
en deux le pays des divisions 2 si comme
dit l'adage après la pluie vient le beau
temps l'orage pourrait continuer de
gronder encore un peu au dessus de la
résidence du premier ministre
et pour l'analyse on retrouve donc un
top blanche maison expert en relations
internationales alors loin ou pas loin
ce départ à ce que ça risque de coûter
son poste à boris johnson on va se
contenter peut-être éventuellement de
sanctions ce qui est sûr c'est que boris
johnson le transgressif qui a amené son
parti à la victoire électorale est
devenu aujourd'hui pour le parti
conservateur
un vrai problème et le fait que
l'opposition le parti travailliste
demande sa démission n'a pas beaucoup
d'importance puisque le parti
conservateur à une très large majorité
aux communes c'est donc le parti
conservateur qui doit estimer à quel
moment boris johnson devient plus gênant
c'est à dire à quel moment ils risquent
de faire perdre les élections et son
local dans quelques mois en
grande-bretagne et il a probablement
contribué à la perte d'une
circonscription acquise aux
conservateurs au mois de décembre
dernier et effectivement c'est l'équipe
qui dirige le parti conservateur qui
doit décider si et quand le remplacer et
par qui alors et bien sûr il ya des
appétits qui sont déclarés parmi les
appétits il ya également des études et
sondages et on dit généralement que le
ministre des finances est sur les rangs
et qu'il pourrait être un jeune premier
ministre britannique il a 41 ans il est
brillant et on pourrait on dit aussi la
même chose de la ministre des affaires
étrangères madame strauss on a dit aussi
la même chose mais c'était il ya quinze
jours ça change tout le temps de la
ministre de l'intérieur donc
on en parle beaucoup mais je pense qu'en
effet avec son culot boris johnson est
encore installé dans la place et pour un
certain temps alors au delà de ce
scandale un cc la stratégie sanitaire
qui divise jusque dans les rangs 1 vous
lisiez aussi du parti conservateur oui
en effet comme dans beaucoup d'autres
pays le nouveau variant fait des ravages
en grande bretagne mais boris johnson
est très attaché à ne pas empêcher
l'économie de fonctionner par conséquent
il est plutôt dû dans le dans le dans le
sens de garder les l'économie ouverte et
l'économie doit doit fonctionner par
conséquent de restreindre autant que
faire se peut les restrictions qui
deviennent de plus en plus nécessaire
avec ce variant qui fait que le service
de santé britannique est complètement
débordé aujourd'hui alors tout
blanchemaison vous restez s'il vous
plaît avec nous puisque on va aborder on
l'a dit un autre sujet à hong kong qui
vient de décider d'une série de
nouvelles infractions à la sécurité
nationale
à terme ce nouveau texte on rendra
illégal presque toute forme de
dissidence nicolas petit
les rangs du conseil législatif sont
clairsemés et pour cause face à cary
l'âme qui s'apprête à prendre la parole
seul des grands électeurs qui partage la
ligne politique du gouvernement peuvent
siéger ce mercredi la chef de l'exécutif
leur a fait part de l'adoption à venir
d'une nouvelle loi un complément aux
textes drastiques sur la sécurité
nationale imposées par pékin en 2020
la loi sur la sécurité nationale adoptée
par le comité permanent de l'assemblée
nationale populaire le 30 juin et une
loi extrêmement bien écrite elle est
appliquée depuis environ un an et demi
sa fonction initiale était de mettre fin
à la violence et au chaos pour revenir à
la normale n'est pas maintenant elle
sert de point d'ancrage pour garantir la
stabilité pour faire savoir aux gens
qu'il y a des conséquences la loi sur la
sécurité nationale nous impose de
prévenir de réprimer de punir les crimes
si la prévention est bien fait nous
avons moins besoin de sanctionner des
bons par la législation dollars kl 23
seraient tout aussi bien écrite
l'article 23 de la loi fondamentale
sorte de mini constitution du territoire
rétrocédée à la chine en 1997
prévoit que hong kong légifère pour sa
propre sécurité nationale car il am a
annoncé qu'il comprendrait une
quarantaine d'infractions un tour de vis
supplémentaire donc pour l'ex colonie
britannique où la plupart des opposants
politiques sont désormais emprisonnés
ont dû arrêter ou encore fuir à
l'étranger ces derniers jours des médias
ont également fait les frais du contexte
autoritaire sur l'archipel après
l'arrestation de journalistes d'un autre
média ceux de citizen news ont préféré
fermer leurs sites d'information et
cesser leur activité
les indications sont claires tous les
médias sont confrontés à un
environnement de plus en plus difficiles
qui sont considérés comme critiques ou
fauteurs de troubles sont plus
vulnérables
et c'est pourquoi nous avons pris la
décision de ne pas opérer dans un
contexte d'incertitude
en 2003 le gouvernement avait dû
renoncer à mettre en oeuvre l'article 23
en raison d'importantes manifestations
avec la loi sur la sécurité nationale
imposées par pékin plus rien ne peut
désormais y faire barrage karine ham
souhaite présenter son avant projet
avant la fin juin
la retrouvera donc sur ce plateau club
blanchemaison tout quelle est la portée
de ces nouvelles infractions c'est un
sacré coup porté à la dissidence
pas vraiment parce que le problème est
déjà résolu la loi 2 1020 qui a été voté
par le bureau permanent de l'assemblée
de la chine populaire à pékin a permis
une répression qui du point de vue de
pékin a été très efficace la preuve
comme le montre très bien à votre sujet
les dissidents ne manifestent plus ceux
qui ne sont pas en prison sont partis ou
se taisent les derniers médias
indépendants ont fermé la semaine
dernière et par conséquent le problème
est globalement résolu peut-être est-il
un point à traiter qui est celui des
deux lacs de l'action d'organisations
étrangères ou d'organisations de hong
kong qui travaille avec l'étranger et je
crois que c'est ce point que madame car
il en veut traiter et puis dans le fond
elle a fait élire un nouveau l'écho un
nouveau conseil législatif comme le
disait votre traiter votre votre sujet
avec des gens de toute confiance
puisqu'ils ont été filtrés par pékin et
ben maintenant c'est les travaux
pratiques du legs qu il vient d'être élu
par conséquent il faut qu'il légifère et
on lui donne cette nouvelle loi à voter
avec 40 infractions dont on ne sait pas
exactement quelles sont elles les a pas
du tout énumérer et seul éco va donc
rentrer dans le détail probablement pour
spécifier de nouvelles infractions et
poursuivre les dissidences il compose
encore en trouver en kong justement
alors qu'ici on vise quand on vous
écoute
puisqu'il n'y en a plus vraiment les
médias les puissances étrangères comme
vous dites oui certainement il est le
dernier média indépendant a fermé il ya
quelques jours et puis en effet je crois
que
les chinois et madame karine âmes sont
très soucieux de limiter l'influencé de
l'étranger soit directement après tout
il ya des entreprises étrangères qui
travaillent à hong kong et qui
d'ailleurs commence à se demander s'ils
voudraient pas mieux aller à shanghai
parce que là on a la chine à l'état pur
plutôt que dans l'illusion des libertés
résiduelles en compte qui n'existe plus
qui n'existe plus et par conséquent je
pense qu'on compte en subira les
conséquences sur le plan économique par
ailleurs on a appris il ya quelques
jours la nomination d'un nouveau général
chinois à la tête de la garnison
chinoise de hong kong qui d'ailleurs
n'est pratiquement pas intervenu dans la
pression c'est la police de hong kong
est intervenue mais on a nommé comme
général responsable de la garnison
chinoise de hong kong un général bien
connu qui a réglé les problèmes du sin
kiang et du tibet en organisant des
répressions tout à fait efficace contre
les ouïghours et contre les tibétains
donc je pense que sa seule nomination a
un effet dissuasif sur d'éventuels
dissidents merci beaucoup claude
blanchou maison pour ses analyses merci
à vous
et dans le reste de l'actualité
internationale les provocations de la
corée du nord qui se poursuivent
pyongyang dit avoir testé un missile
hypersonique en présence de kim jong il
le dirigeant nord-coréen aurait
personnellement supervisé le tir le
deuxième de ce type en moins d'une
semaine washington a de son côté décidé
de sanctionner cinq nord coréens les
détails et mme valérie la bonne
kim jung-un en personne a supervisé le
tir de ce missile hypersonique comme on
peut le voir sur ces photos publiées par
l'agencé officielle nord-coréenne
il s'agit du troisième essai d'un
missile hypersonique à vol plané après
celui de septembre 2021 et celui de la
semaine dernière le projectile qui a
atteint une cible en mer à 1000 km de
distance a été tiré au moment d'une
réunion à huis clos du conseil de
sécurité des nations unies sur les
programmes d'armement de pyongyang
nous avons évidemment vu ce lancement
nous sommes très préoccupés le
secrétaire général est très préoccupé
par ce dernier développement et réitère
son appel aux dirigeants de la
république démocratique de corée à se
conformer pleinement à ses obligations
internationales en vertu de toutes les
résolutions pertinentes du conseil de
sécurité et reprendra les pourparlers
avec les autres parties concernées par
la situation dans la péninsule coréenne
comme nous l'avons répété nous sommes
convaincus et pensons que l'engagement
diplomatique est le seul moyen de
parvenir à une paix durable et à une
dénucléarisation complète de la
péninsule coréenne
depuis son accession au pouvoir il ya
dix ans le leader nord coréen kim yong
hyun a beaucoup fait progresser la
technologie militaire de son pays les
missiles hypersonique font partie des
premières priorités du plan quinquennal
comme ont annoncé les médias d'état y
vient en plus rapide et plus maniable
ces missiles sont plus difficiles à
intercepter pour les systèmes de défense
ce qui inquiète fortement les etats-unis
qui font face à un refus de la corée du
nord tente a mené des pourparlers sur sa
dénucléarisation
il n'y a pas de conditions préalables
nous pensons que la diplomatie et le
dialogue sont une option viable pour le
moment il un conte selon nous à la
république populaire
mocratique de corée de mettre fin à ses
provocations pour démontrer qu'elle
aussi est intéressé et espérons le
sérieuse à propos de ce dialogue ainsi
elle l'est elle trouvera chez les états
unis et ses alliés une contrepartie pour
s'engager dans ce dialogue
le dialogue entre pyongyang et
washington est dans l'impasse depuis
2019 et l'échec des pourparlers entre ki
moon et donald trump joe biden a tenté à
plusieurs reprises de renouer les
discussions mais payant bien aussi
refusé accusant les états unis de mener
une politique hostile la corée du nord
fait l'objet de sanctions
internationales pour ses programmes
d'armement interdit
en france un hommage a été rendu
aujourd'hui aux victimes de la rue de
trévise à paris il ya trois ans un jour
pour jour une violente explosion de gaz
a soufflé une grande partie de cette rue
située dans le 9e arrondissement
myans de ce drame quatre morts et 66
blessés une commémoration à laquelle ont
participé riverains et élus parmi eux
anne hidalgo elle est maire ps de paris
qui est vite reparti et par les
habitants une commémoration qui
intervient après l'accord trouvé pour
indemniser les victimes et détaillée
avec notre reporter katia technique
la catastrophe est survenue ici le 2
janvier 2010 9 rue de trévise dans le
neuvième arrondissement de paris une
explosion sous une boulangerie à semer
le chaos et soufflé des immeubles le
bilan humain est très lourd quatre morts
dont deux pompiers et 66 blessés 300
sinistrés ont dû être relogés en ce
moment il ya les commémorations du
troisième anniversaire les
investigations ont permis de déterminer
l'origine du sinistre la rupture d'une
canalisation de gaz un ouvrage municipal
de responsables de la catastrophe sont
désignés par les magistrats la ville de
paris et le syndic de copropriété de
l'immeuble la compagnie immobilière sipa
ils ont été mis en examen en septembre
2020 notamment pour homicides et
blessures involontaires
en cause les pressions exercées sur la
conduite de gaz par le trottoir de la
rue de trévise qui s'affaissait cela a
causé la rupture du tube et la fuite de
gaz pourtant de nombreuses réflexions de
ce trottoir avaient été effectués depuis
2014 le dossier pointe la mauvaise
gestion de la voirie du service de
l'inspection des eaux et des
canalisations le manque de suivi le
manque de coordination de relever fiable
la déperdition d'informations la ville
réfute pour le moment sa responsabilité
le syndic de copropriété n'a pour sa
part pas réalisé à l'époque les travaux
qu'ils devaient faire trois ans plus
tard toutes les victimes de cette
effroyable explosions n'ont été que
partiellement indemnisés alors que
d'autres catastrophes du même type avait
rapidement trouver une issue certaines
victimes sont toujours dans un état
grave tel inès une jeune fille très
grièvement blessé durant l'explosion les
jambes atrocement mutilé elle a subi 42
opérations sa vie est devenue un
véritable enfer à l'interpeller mantois
la maire de paris sur son compte twitter
car elle doit financer ses soins mais le
2 c'est d'indemnisation n'est toujours
pas bouclé illégitime plus de temps
derniers véhicules sont fatigués en a
qui sont à l'hôpital on n'en peut plus
vraiment et pour toutes les personnes
qui nous critiquent en dix ans et fut
histoire d'argent encore une fois on est
à l'hôpital et des opérations qu'on paye
même si vous pouvez les payer bah c'est
que messi nous laisser nous battre parce
que c'est ce qu'on vous doit de toute
façon la mairie de paris était jusqu'ici
accusé de jouer la montre de privilégier
les procédures les plus lentes son
argument elle n'aurait pas le droit de
verser des provisions tant que les
fondements juridiques de la
responsabilité sans faute n'ont pas été
étudiées mais réunion épuisante pour les
victimes se sont enchaînées sans que
rien n'avance anne hidalgo vient
d'accepter de signer un accord de
principe validant l'accord cadre
d'indemnisation la ville provisionnera
20 millions d'euros sans attendre le
terme de la procédure pénale une somme
qui ne présume toutefois pas de la
culpabilité de la ville le syndic de
copropriété sera également mis à
contribution ainsi que le fournisseur de
gaz grdf mais les montants n'ont pas été
communiqués lors de l'hommage certaines
personnes sont venues avec des stylos
pour rappeler anne hidalgo qu'elle
n'avait toujours pas signé l'accord
certaines personnes ont même eu lui et
la maire de paris un soutien des
victimes nous explique qu'il ya eu un
semblant de demande de signature s'est
toujours pas signée par contre lundi à
une un conseil de paris extraordinaire
qui va parler du sujet donc on espère
donc c'est pour ça qu'on est là avec des
stylos pour que ça soit signé une fois
pour toutes certaines victimes ne sont
toujours pas indemnisés ne sont pas pris
en charge donc de tous leurs frais sont
à leur charge donc voilà aujourd'hui ce
qui se passe c'est que les gens ça fait
trois ans que cet autre n est que ils
sont en souffrance alors que s'achèvent
les hommages du troisième anniversaire
de l'explosion de combien auraient
besoin les victimes pourraient être
indemnisées pour leurs préjudices
corporels mais aussi mobilier de 200
millions d'euros le procès quant à lui
pour aller dans plusieurs années et on
l'évoquait hier la commission brauner a
rendu son rapport sur la désinformation
via internet dossier remis au moment où
le président en français emmanuel macron
présenté ses voeux à la presse un
rapport est bien critiqué notamment pour
sa mise en application utopique david
kelly cent trente propositions contre
les fêtes ni aux talons d'achille du
numérique la désinformation est un fléau
que veut combattre emmanuel macron le
sociologue gérald bronner a été
missionné par le chef de l'état pour
proposer des solutions
lancé fin septembre ce projet ambitieux
a vu naître un rapport modestement
intitulé les lumières à l'ère du
numérique des recommandations élaborées
à l'issue de trois mois d'états des
lieux ont donc été présenté au président
est cette semaine le timing fait
forcément parler au moment où les anti
vaccins taxé de complotisme sont pointés
du doigt par l'exécutif des individus
vivent dans la même société mais pas
dans le même monde mental certains
mondes mentaux peuvent parfois aboutir à
des actions concrètes comme la défiance
vaccinale ces recommandations ne vise
pas éradiqué mais a limité la viralité
des contenus qui affaiblissent la
démocratie car la liberté d'opinion
reste l'un des fondements de la
démocratie
joliment dit pourtant pour l'élaboration
de ces travaux menés par gérald bronner
ça avait plutôt mal commencé le
sociologue ne sait pas forcément entouré
des meilleurs pour rédiger ce document
guy vallancien notamment mis en cause
par la pneumologue élan ce galet irène
frachon pour avoir nié la gravité de la
sphère du médicament médiator l'urologue
avait très vite annoncé qu'il renonçait
à participer à ce projet au vu de la
polémique naissante mais ce n'est pas
tout la légitimité de gérald bronner lui
même et pour certains sujette à caution
selon sa fiche wikipédia gérald bronner
le sociologue chargé de conduire pour
macron la mission anti fait news a été
pris deux fois en flagrant délit de
diffusion de cette news la mise en place
du ministère de la vérité macro nist
commence mal paradoxal quand on est
censé se poser en juge de paix sur un
sujet aussi épineux que la
désinformation mais peu importe la
polémique rapidement étouffées et gérald
bronner et 13 autres chercheurs ont pu
travailler sereinement pour établir
leurs recommandations plusieurs
ressortent d'abord mieux maîtriser les
logiques algorithmique c'est à dire
lutter contre les dangers de la
popularité en ligne de mire les
influenceurs en effet les algorithmes
ont tendance à privilégier les contenus
fournis par les contes les plus suivis
encourager les plateformes à une
modération plus attentif des
influenceurs afin de les responsabiliser
les conséquences des informations
produites ou diffusés par un conte doté
d'une grande visibilité numérique sont
potentiellement plus importante que pour
des comptes de faibles audiences une
idée qui peut s'apparenter à une
certaine forme de censure mais sans la
prononcer l'autre point important
mentionné par ce rapport c'est
l'investissement publicitaire
responsable objectif éviter que la
publicité en ligne deviennent financer
les sites de désinformation ou couple
autistes des acteurs comme muse ward a
global design formation index ou stories
y ont justement mise au point des listes
répertorions les sites et éviter et sont
cités en exemple sauf que pour certains
d'entre eux la fiabilité des
recommandations semble elle aussi elle
très discutable news brown notamment
dont le comité consultatif roberge d'aix
de la cia de la nsa de l'otan ou de la
maison blanche est épinglée pour ses
pratiques à des fins commerciales est
accusé de labelliser l'info à sa sauce
dans l'esprit des manuels macron qui il
dit fox news dit forcément ingérence
étrangère et qui dit ingérence étrangère
dit forcément russie en tout cas selon
le rapport qui veut mettre en place un
dispositif de coopération entre
plateformes institutions et communauté
académique pour réagir rapidement aux
opérations détectée sauf que l'exemple
de la russie est sans fondement les
opérations d'ingérence menée par la
russie lors de l'élection présidentielle
de 2016 ont complètement pris au
dépourvu l'administration américaine
comme les plateformes et ajouter une
couche de complexité au problème des
allégations pompée directement sur celle
des services de renseignement américain
n'est jamais prouvé le kremlin dénonce
d'ailleurs je cite est des accusations
absolument infondée la commission
brodeur est une initiative à saluer
certes mais plusieurs recommandations
semble pour le moins controversé chacun
se fera sa propre opinion
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous parlerons de la lutte contre le coc
vide en france le sénat poursuit ce soir
l'examen du projet de loi qui transforme
le pass sanitaire en passe vaccinale le
sénat qui refusent que les cafetiers et
restaurateurs effectué des vérifications
d'identité dans notre rubrique qu'en
pensent les français nous irons
justement à la rencontre de l'un d'entre
eux un restaurateur parisien très
inquiet pour l'avenir de son
établissement alors les petits patrons
grandes victimes de la crise qu vide on
répondra on tentera en tout cas répondre
à cette question
[Musique]
chacun prétend détenir la vérité trop
souvent il ne s'agit que de spéculations
[Musique]
le travail de julian et de wikileaks
nous a montré toute une série de
meurtres la corruption la profonde
criminalité des états unis et de leurs
alliés de l'otan
ce sa page de réputation qui a commencé
quasiment immédiatement après la
publication des irakiens warlogs
l'isolent de la société
le new york times
le washington post
der spiegel hugo
ils ont tous publié exactement la même
chose vu juste mais la violence du
royaume uni et de ses agents
cela donne la nausée
aviez vous été surpris que ces organes
de presse qui ont publié ces
informations se soit ensuite retournés
contre julian
et bien non pas vraiment 1 je dirais
déçu oui mais pas surpris
[Musique]
bienvenue dans ces caches une émission
consacrée cette semaine aux gros titres
de l'actualité économique les aides pour
les entreprises affectés par les
restrictions sanitaires doit être
renforcé et élargi on rentre à nouveau
dans un cercle en effet infernal dead
qui n'en finit pas et on se demande
jusqu'où ça va aller on sait que de
toute façon on l'a dit dit fois quand
l'état paye c'est qu'il est assez vous
c'est nous le volume mondial des fusions
et acquisitions a dépassé en 2021 pour
la première toile 5 milliards dollars
comme il y a eu en fait une pause avec
locaux vides puisque no 6 se dire faut
relativiser ce phénomène en disant que
c'est aussi la raison pour laquelle on a
eu autant cette année parce que
néanmoins à l'année d'avant l'euro fête
ses 20 ans cette année c'est une police
qui a fait ses preuves selon vous en
effet et le voilà le bilan est mitigé
gameiro des gagnants et des perdants le
gagnant incontestablement où sont les
taxes ou les impôts
et les perdants le reste
[Musique]
un certain nombre de journalistes eux
semblent s'être octroyé un pouvoir de
juger à pouvoir même de condamner c'est
extrêmement dangereux parce que moi
j'aime savoir d'où parle les gens j'ai
cherché j'ai su trouver des réponses
mais émettra 20 suis jamais à oger une
qualité ou une compétence ou une
expertise que je n'avais pas je pense
que notre métier devrait un peu douté de
ses bases et les revoir et les remettre
en question toujours eu un rôle
historique pour le meilleur et pour le
pire d'ailleurs parce que si on était un
petit allemands dans les années 30 on
l'a beaucoup entendu hitler et ses potes
à la radio puis toutes les choses graves
j'ai l'impression qu'on les apprend par
la radio quand on écoute la radio c'est
si c'est grave ou si c'est pas grave
plus qu'à la télé
[Musique]
comment abordez vous cette épreuve vous
êtes vous rendu au procès je suis allé
aux premières auditions du procès j'ai
trouvé vraiment que le monde finalement
était formé de gens merveilleux et de
aidé de jean ignoble en fait vous ne
savez pas comment votre fils est mort
vous devez enquêter sur tout et vous
confronter ils étaient ni sur la liste
des morts nés sur la bbc une
surveillance et hopitalisé il était
nulle part est ce qu'on peut vivre
malgré cette douleur quand j'ai écrit à
la fois je souffrais parce que ça me
rappelait des beaux souvenirs avec
stéphane en même temps c'était très
douloureux et puis aujourd'hui je me
suis aperçu que ça permettait d'extraire
de de moi même toute cette histoire est
donc ça m'a apporté un peu de recul un
peu d'apaisement mais la douleur et la
colère seront là jusqu'à ma mort
[Musique]
il est 21h merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième partie d'émission au
sommaire la lutte anti commises en
france le seynois poursuit ce soir
l'examen du projet de loi qui transforme
le pas de sanitaires en passe vaccinale
plus d'une centaine d'amendements sont
débattues en ce moment les sénateurs qui
ont voté une mesure prévoyant
l'extinction automatique du dispositif
en dessous d'un certain seuil
d'hospitalisation les modifications
majeures contre l'avis du gouvernement
et autres changements importants le
sénat qui refusent que les cafetiers et
restaurateurs effectué des vérifications
d'identité des patrons soulager
puisqu'ils doivent déjà demandé des
pâtes sanitaires à tous leurs clients
une mesure bien lourde qui a fait
parfois baisser la fréquentation selon
les restaurants dont notre rubrique
qu'en pensent les français se soit on
ira à la rencontre d'un restaurateur
parisien très inquiet pour son avenir
alors les petits patrons grandes
victimes de la crise qu vide on attend
vos réactions sur notre compte
télégramme rt france
[Musique]
le projet de loi sur le pass vaccinale à
l'épreuve des saynètes en ce moment un
texte qui connaît donc d'ores et déjà
des modifications importantes on
retrouve notre reporter lucas léger
devant le sénat bonsoir lucas les
sénateurs qui a donc instauré dans ce
projet des mesures qui font grincer des
dents au sein du gouvernement
[Musique]
absolument le débat a repris sur le pass
vaccinale après les questions au
gouvernement comme il était passé devant
la commission des lois lundi il y avait
des points très divergents avec le
gouvernement notamment la possibilité un
amendement a été déposé en ce sens de
supprimer le pass vaccinale
automatiquement lorsque les
hospitalisations pour coville 19 sont en
dessous de dix mille dans toute la
france dans les départements où il ya
une bonne couverture vaccinale
interrogé sur ce point à gabriella
talent sur europe 1 déclaré aujourd'hui
que de toute façon le gouvernement ne
comptait pas que cette même affaire de
cette mesure une mesure permanente ce
n'est pas un projet de société at il dit
la commission des lois veut aussi que le
pass vaccinale ne soit pas appliquée aux
moins de 18 ans les moins de 18 ans qui
resteront par contre avec cette version
toujours soumis aux passes sanitaires
ils veulent aussi que le certificat de
rétablissement soit clairement intégré
au pass vaccinale et enfin pour les
sanctions ils veulent des sanctions
allégée pour les détenteurs de faux
passe trois ans de prison et 45000 euros
d'amendé contre 50 prison et 75000 euros
d'amendé dans le projet initial et le
cas l'année dernière donc le sénat a par
ailleurs décidé de supprimer la
vérification d'identité par les
restaurateurs
oui absolument et ils sont allés plus
loin que ce que voulait la commission
des mois puisque la commission des lois
a proposé de simplifier cette procédure
avec notamment la possibilité de
contrôler la carte vitale ou le permis
de conduire il faudra sur ce point et
sur tous les autres que les députés et
les sénateurs se mettent d'accord en
commission mixte paritaire et le
gouvernement de son côté veut rentrer
dans la phase de mise en application à
partir de lundi merci le cas légers en
direct du sénat et c'est donc un
soulagement pour une partie des
restaurateurs et cafetiers qui
n'accueillait pas très bien cette
vérification d'identité des
établissements qui doivent déjà demandé
donc les pattes sanitaires à leurs
clients dans notre rubrique en pensent
les français ce soir nous sommes allés à
la rencontre de l'un de ses patrons
stéphane mal chaussés son nom dirige la
célèbre masri brasserie mollahs arts à
paris depuis le début de la crise il
réplique tout les règles pour lutter
contre la pandémie mais avec l'explosion
du nombre de cas la crainte de devoir
refermer refait surface un reportage
signé estelle farge et sébastien dufour
je suis dans le 8e arrondissement de
paris je vais rencontrer stéphane mal
chaussé le patron d'une grande brasserie
parisienne comment ce restaurateur
vit-il la crise sanitaire quel est son
état d'esprit venez on va aller lui
demander
bonjour monsieur bell et shaw bon jour
là en tant que restaurateurs vous avez
dû à vous payer à tout un nouveau
protocole sanitaire est ce que ça a été
compliqué à mettre en place pour sa part
été très compliquée à mettre en place il
faut s'équiper du matériel adéquat faut
expliquer à notre personnel qu'est ce
qu'il faut faire qu'est ce que vous
pensez vous de ce protocole sanitaire
écoutez faut tout faire pour que nous
n'ayons plus l'obligation de fermer à
nouveau on est habitué aux normes aux
lois et aux règlements ou
au changement administratif et social
régulier
donc mettre cette organisation en place
c'est un petit peu de travail en amont
mais pas être contraints de fermer
l'établissement c'est l'une de vos peurs
aujourd'hui ça vous êtes inquiet ah oui
on n'a pas envie de faire mais oui ça
c'est clair j'avais peur que ça puisse
se reproduire
on écoute et on n'en parle pas mais oui
ça reste une crainte justement est-ce
que ça a été vous avez été fermé de
nombreux mois est-ce que ça a été
compliqué pour vous de remettre en route
la machine c'était compliqué dans le
sens où notre établissement est ouvert
tous les jours toute l'année on n'est
jamais fermée donc
on n'a pas l'habitude de fermer pour une
période de un mois et donc on n'a pas
l'habitude et réouvrir après une longue
période de fermeture comme on la connaît
vous avez eu quelques difficultés on a
été surpris par le matériel qui tombait
en panne notamment toutes les
installations frigorifiques vous
démontrez je vais vous montrer par ici
vous avez ici des condenseurs qui ne
marchait plus vous aviez les charnières
qui était grippé
les l'octo qui marchait plus ou alors on
a eu des fuites de gaz dans les
installations frigorifiques
ce qui a occasionné des frais de
réparation dépannage aujourd'hui il ya
une variante mikron qui a fait son
apparition dans quel état d'esprit ce
que vous êtes aujourd'hui écoutez c'est
si on vit une période sans précédent en
chef d'entreprise de voir son commerce
fermé réouvrir refermée pour réouvrir
alors on n'a pas peur
mais il ya un petit côté déstabilisant
mais de toute manière quand on est
commerçant cette angoisse elle est
inhérente globalement aux chefs
d'entreprise c'est une angoisse
supplémentaires par rapport au quotidien
d'un chef d'entreprise et d'un dirigeant
de restants mais c'est pas insurmontable
après quand on en parle et on entend
parler quatrième vague cinquième vague
restriction tout ça sont des éléments
qui vont contraindre l'activité
économique donc contraindre la
fréquentation des restaurants et de
notre établissement
donc on vit pas une période euphorique
timorés je vous propose qu'on s'assied
pour la suite
on est à quelques mois de la
présidentielle
vous en tant que chef d'entreprise
qu'est ce que vous avez envie d'entendre
pendant cette campagne de quoi est ce
que vous avez envie qu'on parle on
souhaiterait pour nous les petits
commerçants et globalement toutes les
pme les entreprises une certaine
stabilité fiscale dans le temps
on aimerait une réelle simplification de
l'administration de nos entreprises on
nous arrête donc voilà c'est tout les
normes les règlements les changements
met des bâtons dans les roues
aujourd'hui ah oui c'est compliqué
aujourd'hui faire une fiche de paye
c'est compliqué les salariés ne
comprennent plus leur fiche de paye ils
viennent nous voir pour savoir comment
ça marche
on nous impose le prélèvement à la
source donc faut le mettre en place pour
l'expliquer aux salariés là on va
distribuer la prime de 100 euros la
prime inflation c'est l'entreprise qui
valent à collecter auprès des salariés
après c'est l'entreprise qui se fera
rembourser par le trésor public mais
faut pas oublier que tout ça c'est du
travail pour les administratifs des
entreprises ça n'est pas simple pendant
qu'on fait ça on fait pas autre chose et
c'est pas pour autant qu'on est rémunéré
c'est un problème aujourd'hui est les
tâches administratives
bah c'est la compliquer ça c'est évident
je me souviens qu'un président parlait
de simplification administrative
on la recherche encore si vous aviez un
message aujourd'hui a adressé aux
candidats à la présidentielle ce serait
quoi venez vous régaler dans nos
restaurants
ne manquera pas en tout cas la lourdeur
administrative qui en plus du coc bide
mais le moral des petits patrons dans
les chaussettes emmanuel macron avait
pourtant promis de réformer ce fameux
millefeuille administratif français le
présent qui ajuste supprimer l'ena et
puis le coc bild est passée par là d'où
notre question ce soir les petits
patrons sont-ils les grandes victimes de
la crise qu vide on attend toujours vos
réactions sur le comté d g liberté
france et c'est l'heure de notre face à
face
[Musique]
et avec nous pour en parler ce soir donc
pierre cabaret député la république en
marche de la haute-garonne bonsoir
pierre cabaret merci d'être avec nous à
vos côtés charles prat sorgues orateurs
national de la cellule riposte de
valérie pécresse candidate évidemment
dlr à la présidentielle 2022 merci
d'être avec nous une réaction tout
d'abord à ce témoignage qu'on vient
d'entendre on sent vraiment
l'exaspération de notre restaurateur il
a aussi entre les fermetures les
ouvertures il a respecté les règles il a
critiqué beaucoup la lourdeur
administrative il dit surtout vous
l'avez entendu que le président eh bien
il tient pas ses promesses il devait
simplifier on s'en souvient à la vie des
entrepreneurs avec notamment une réforme
de l'administration ça ne va pas
vraiment été fait pierre au cabaret
d'abord ce que j'entends c'est
l'inquiétude sur les fermetures et
l'inquiétude sur l'avenir mais ça on la
partage avec lui ensuite
et bien
lundi soir nous avons voté nous avons
voté le plan indépendant alors ce plan
indépendant ça simplifie le cadre et ça
effectivement répond à un certain nombre
de ces interrogations et puis je
voudrais vous dire que vous avez oublié
une chose mais je vous l'avais pas dit
je suis moi-même artisans alors donc les
entreprises je connais et je connais
cette traversée est tout ce que le
gouvernement appuie faire pour que nous
puissions traverser ce moment et ça va
justement au niveau de la lourdeur
administrative parce qu'ils passent on
entend ici ou là quand même fier cabaret
là je m'adresse à l'artisan vous êtes
alors la lourdeur administrative
évidemment ça va mieux et ça va aider
encore mieux puisque lundi soir dernier
je vous dis on a voté ce plan
indépendant qui va nous toucher de près
et qui va toucher de près chaque
entreprise chaque petite entreprise et
chaque entrepreneur et je les remercie
parce que c'est vrai que traverser cette
crise est difficile et il faut un peu
d'espérance aussi chapatte vous voyez
faire des grands mouvements
la lourdeur année fanny le millefeuille
et indigeste oui bof sèche je suis
juriste parce que la profession moi je
suis magistrat j'ai un petit peu de
neige avant j'étais fonctionnaire chez
inspecteurs et dolce fonctionne un
ministère des finances il se trouve que
alors je ne suis pas artisans et j'ai
une petite connaissance des règles
juridiques applicables aux chefs
d'entreprise aux entreprises et même aux
particuliers
et je suis bien incapable même moi de
vous dire combien il y à deux milliers
de pages par exemple dans le code
général des impôts français dans la
réglementation sociale applicable enfin
c'est on est en france c'est un truc
hallucinant et tous les chefs
d'entreprise qui nous écoutent le savent
très bien leur expert-comptable le
savent très bien enfin ça c'est du
délire c'est à dire qu'on est quand même
dans le pays où le nombre de règles sont
absurdes les règles fiscales des règles
sociales toutes celles qui étrangle
réellement la vie économique du pays qui
pourrissent la vie des français au
quotidien que ce soit les chefs
d'entreprise ou les particuliers si vous
voulez le problème de la france c'est
que rappelez-vous des douze travaux
d'astérix à l'époque c'était l'immeuble
des fous vous savez l'immeuble qui rend
fou avec le formulaire b 32 et bah en
fait
déjà à l'époque goscinny et uderzo se
moquer de la complexité administrative
française et bien aujourd'hui en 2022
c'est pire que tout et c'est
effectivement un des grands échecs des
manuels macron c'est de ne pas avoir du
tout simplifier les règles à tel point
que vous avez même un candidat à la
présidentielle qui vient de se présenter
en disant moi je veux enfin simplifier
les règles donc ces noms là dessus il
faut arrêter de prendre les gens pour
des imbéciles
il suffit simplement de regarder un code
général des impôts il suffit d'aller
regarder la réglementation de l'urssaf
d'ailleurs même les services de l'urssaf
des fois ne comprennent même pas leurs
règles et ne savent même pas les
appliquer pour les gencives aller sur
internet ils regardent légifrance 1 le
site internet des règles juridiques
applicables on vote d'énormes vous êtes
député à l'assemblée nationale vous
voter des lois tout le temps on crée
d'énormes l'europe nous rajoute des
normes on n'arrête pas les lois les
décrets à les arrêter les circulaires
tout nous a plus personne ne comprend
rien à rien le dernier exemple en date
un bras c'était là le protocole
sanitaire dans les écoles un pataquès
incommensurable depuis plusieurs jours
on voit ce que ça donne
voilà à tel point que même le président
de la république rue comprendre a dit
oui non là ça a plu quoi voilà donc non
là véritablement et c'est d'ailleurs une
des raisons on pourra parler peut-être
après 206 passes pour les restaurateurs
les actions des petites gens etc mais
oui là on touche du doigt véritablement
un vrai problème français c'est cette
complexité administrative
qui est source d'incompréhension qui est
source d'erreurs qui est source de
fraude aussi parce que plus vous
complexifier les règles plus vous
permettez aux gens de les contourner
donc on est au coeur du mal français et
à ce cas évidemment s'ajoute cette crise
sanitaire on l'a entendu avec ce
témoignage d'où notre question du soir
les petits patrons sont-ils des grandes
victimes de la crise qu vide c'est vrai
que la situation des des restaurateurs
et ne fait pas vraiment rêver on va
regarder un groupement national des
indépendants hôteliers et restauration
qui a fait des mécontents avec les
annulations et la désertification des
restaurants en termes d'activité qu'est
ce que ça donne et bien regardez moins
93% pour les cafetiers en baisse
d'activité évidemment des restaurants en
décembre 2021 - 91% pour les traiteurs
moins 85 pour les restaurateurs ça fait
lourd tout de même pierre cabaret qu'est
ce que ça vous inspire ces chiffres
sachant que ça y est maintenant le cas
qu'ils ont coûté bien c'est terminé
d'abord je voudrais revenir sur l'aspect
très noir que vous donnez équipier chez
un monsieur si nous avions ce trou sans
fond que vous imaginez que vous laisser
imaginer on n'aurait pas un demi million
d'emplois créés cette terre deux
dernières années et on aurait des
tendances et des failles d'entreprise en
pagaille alors que depuis 1986 eh bien
nous n'avons jamais eu un taux de
faillite aussi aussi faible donc je
crois qu'il faut pas noircir le tableau
mais arrêtons de noircir ce tableau
arrêtez-vous aussi de noircir le tableau
et vouloir si c'est pour une raison
parce que finalement ce que pécresse
propose macron l'a déjà fait et ça nous
l'avons fait encore hier soir avec avec
cette idée là dotons si on prend les
cafetiers évidemment que les castillon
une baisse évidemment mais cette baisse
c'est pas le quoi qu'il en coûte qui est
important c'est cette baisse elle est
compensée par des aides et effectivement
on traverse une mesure avec des mesures
encourageant et bien on traverse une
situation difficile il faut arrêter de
donner une image au tir et a vanté
les aime continue le fonds de solidarité
entreprises continuent jusqu'à la fin du
mois donc les aides sont pas arrêtées et
ensuite les aides en fonction de ce qui
arrive pourront avoir une réactivité
plus importante donc je crois que sur ça
il faut vraiment être dans l'actualité
je crois pour avoir une vision un peu
loyale qu'est ce que vous répondez à
pierre cabaret qu'on y va voilà ce que
valérie pécresse aimerait faire
justement sur ce type de problématique
macron l'a déjà fait non
il faut alors sur les aides et sur la
traversée avec ce qu'on appelle quoi
qu'il en coûte etc il faut effectivement
reconnaître bord c'est pas emmanuel
macron bourg ne maîtrise pas les
ministres le président qui décide en
réalité ce type de dispositif non plus
non mais tout à fait ce type de
dispositif ils ne sont conçus au
ministère des finances un d'économie et
des finances par des hauts
fonctionnaires qui sont compétents et
face à la crise qu vite parce qu'il ya
une décision politique un nombre donné
de fermeture de confinement et cetera de
l'activité il a été décidé de mettre en
place deux choses le chômage partiel qui
a d'ailleurs été mis en place de manière
open bars et donc avec des fraudes
monstrueuse parce que le gouvernement
n'avait pas voulu écouter notamment non
partis politiques plus délicat et
proposer des amendements pour sécuriser
les paiements moralité on s'est fait
voler des millions et de dizaines de
millions voire des centaines de millions
d'euros par les fraudeurs habituels
qu'on connaît mais bon ça c'est comme ça
et après il ya eu aussi dispositif du
fonds de solidarité qui est un petit peu
différent mais c'est dispose il est bien
sûr les pêcheuses qu'on appelle des
prêts garantis par l'état qui ont permis
effectivement à tout un tas
d'entreprises de la plus petite à la
plus grande d'essayer de traverser la
crise et effectivement d'ailleurs si
vous regardez les statistiques des des
faillites vous rendez compte que malgré
une baisse très importante du pib un
nombre d'activités économiques en
réalité vous avez eu une baisse des
défaillances d'autres enfin de petites
entreprises sur les plus grandes
entreprises vous avez une augmentation
très forte des défaillances
d'entreprises la dernière fois plus 78%
de mémoire d'après une étude deloitte
qui avaient été publiées en mai 2021 est
par contre sur les petites entreprises
les artisans les commerçants on avait
une baisse des défaillances
d'entreprises qui peut apparaître contre
intuitif en fait ça c'est le mécanisme
de fonctionnement du pge qui a été conçu
par les fonctionnaires de bercy
évidemment le gouvernement
sans en tirer gloire parce que c'est lui
qui est aux affaires mais
alors il a il peut avoir tort de
s'inquiéter par rapport aux aides parce
que malgré tout comme nous sommes nous
en aller année électorale il mène le
maquereau évidemment maintient à
perfusion du poids qu'il en coûte parce
que sinon vous auriez à un nombre de
défaillances très important et ça ne
peut pas se le permettre en année
électorale en revanche là où il a raison
de s'inquiéter c'est sur la baisse de
fréquentation vous avez souligner et
cette baisse de fréquentation par
exemple elle est due à des mesures là
qui pour la peine sont des mesures
politiques -dont des décisions
politiques qui sont parfois totalement
absurde permettez-moi de le dire mais
quand vous êtes dans un bistrot et qu'on
vient vous dire non vous n'avez pas le
droit de boire votre café debout faut le
boire à 6 je suis désolé mais le virus
du coc vide il vole pas simplement au
dessus d'un mètre cinquante cas voilà
donc et c'est d'ailleurs tout le monde a
rigolé et tout le monde s'est moqué de
ces mesures un petit peu absurdes qui
ont été prises et qui sont
symptomatiques de la manière dont le
gouvernement parfois un gers cette
affaire là de manière un petit peu
bizarre et du moins les gens ne
comprennent pas certaines décisions qui
sont prises rires oui
alésia désigne non je voulais justement
rebondir pascal des qui nous dit
tout dépend des petits patrons milliards
il n'y a jamais eu de crise de co2 du
coc villebon lui c'est son avis voilà et
ça n'engage que lui mais une crise
politique due à de l'incompétence
flagrante et qui a mis plein de gens
debout ou à genoux alors non là je
m'inscris 1 x est pas une incompétence
des gens encore une fois alors c'est mon
côté ancien de bercy qui parle mais les
fonctionnaires du ministère des finances
qui ont conçu ces plans qui les ont mis
en oeuvre etc sont au contraire très
compétent et on leur doit d'avoir passé
la crise mais comme depuis des siècles
on doit à la l'état au système de l'état
globalement de permettre à la france de
traverser les crises de régime des
crises
le point sur le véritable problème c'est
que quoi qu'il en coûte il va bien
falloir rembourser un moment donné et
c'est quand on a cramé la caisse
comme le dit très justement valérie
pécresse on continue de la cram et et
dans le même temps il ya des décisions
mais bon c'est pas le sujet du soir mais
qui sont prises qui sont assez
étonnantes en matière de sécurisation
des recettes de lutte contre la fraude
etc etc ça on va y revenir et c'est que
c'est pas de ta dah et tout serait
vraiment le bienvenu pour en parler un
autre jour ce défaut de gestion qu'elle
fait allusion aux téléspectateurs des
fautes de gestion vous répondez quoi
vous c'est vrai que quand on voit cela
on va pas faire donc eu un débat sur
l'école mais quand on voit répondent
deux choses le système la grève que
d'autres présidents et est à la
manoeuvre jusqu'à au match de l'an
prochain au mois de mai prochain valérie
pécresse effectivement peut toujours
allégué certaines certaines choses on
peut tout se permettre quand on est donc
on ne va pas se permettre nous de faire
des supputations complètement farfelu
j'aimerais sur d'arrêt hier un budget
que nous n'avons pas alors on peut
toujours chercher et contrôler ça je
suis absolument d'accord et tout le
monde est d'accord avec ça on peut
contrôler il faut quand même raison
garder surtout cet argent hypothétique
dont vous parlez et qui n'existe pas
donc sur les hauts fonctionnaires moi je
suis ravie vous parlez vous me parlez
aux fonctionnaires alors ça c'est
formidable aux fonctionnaires qui sont
compétents et à côté de ça vous nous
expliquer que finalement ces mêmes hauts
fonctionnaires 1 parce que vous
l'expliqué aussi nous pondent des lois
complètement dégénérée d'écouté moi je
suis pas d'accord je suis pas d'accord
avec ça il faut avoir une cohérence et
six hauts fonctionnaires ne pompe pas
des lois qui sont inapplicables ils
pondent des lois et il promulgue et nous
promu compter loi chanson happy bien ce
député la fin je voulais vous faire
jouer des lois je vais vous des chutes
et qu'il ait jeté vous prie vous êtes
dans les zones à la république il est
promu
me raconter que ce sont les hauts
fonctionnaires qui les font
effectivement que vous avez la mesure
est elle prépare les mesures vous me
racontez leurs compétences et vous
dénigrez lorsqu'on compétences la
wii mais les offenses commerce est vrai
assez facile de taper sur les gens quand
ils d'abord quand ils sont pas là
ensuite si ça vous à parité pourrait
l'aider quand et si ses fans oui oui oui
on fera pas d'accord la chine d'ailleurs
on n'est pas d'accord pour une chose oui
c'est que nous on gère et madame
pécresse imagine qu'elle peut gérer mais
prenons la raison et à 70% des lycées en
ile-de-france ont besoin d'une
rénovation extrême c'est une gestion
assez acial enfin patrie fidh en tout
cas et pour moi l'éducation c'est
important et c'est important d'y mettre
l'argent nécessaire et à part ça le fait
on va revenir à nos moutons excusez moi
avec cette question quand même des
petits patrons senti les grandes
victimes de la crise vous disiez non
mais enfin regarder quand même ces
chiffres sur les défaillances
d'entreprises les secteurs les plus
impactés hébergement et restauration y
revient - 61 points cet enseignement
santé action sociale services aux
ménages - 51 commerce réparation auto -
47 ça l'air de rien mais enfin ce sont
quand même des des petits métiers des
métiers de proximité
vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec ça les
plus petits n'ont pas souffert l'on
savait christopher plus ils ont souffert
mais si vous voulez le dispositif dead
et ge chômage partiel fonds de
solidarité a permis aux plus petites
entreprises de mieux traverser la crise
d'ailleurs que les grandes ouais mais
c'est d'ailleurs tout le tout la
question c'est que là pour l'instant
l'économie est sous perfusion on a une
espèce de soviétisation de l'économie
les gens sont habitués à ed mais si
c'est un mot qui est tout à fait choisi
je bête tout soviétisation mais bien sûr
mais les salariés du pas en parler dans
doc sont payés arlettaz bon j'appelle ça
la soviétisation ginola économie et ça
va poser un problème de santé de penser
que j'entendrais des choses plus haute
et plus compétentes franchement là
écoutez monsieur le député si vous
voulez parler de compétences dans ce cas
là je vous refais un cours de droit
constitutionnel ce sont les
parlementaires qui votent des lois pas
les hauts fonctionnaires c'est le
président de la république il est promu
il fallait députés et bien moi le
message et de l'introduction des droits
je vais faire je vais donc comme vous
faites encore et constitution je vais
vous faire un cours d'économie puisque
moi-même shirt is an et on travers cette
crise et bien finalement c'est vrai et
vous avez dit on a promulgué un certain
nombre d'événements qui ont fait qu les
gens peuvent traverser cette crise
aujourd'hui est c'est magique parce que
nous avons eu moins de faillites que
vous préférez une faillite vous préférez
des gens de hors jeu les sims est votre
fonds de commerce il annonce le début
d'avoir des d'avoir des chômeurs et vont
fondre comme l orge pas le mien mais moi
je vais bien des gens mais je rappelle
avant 6107 nouveau le nom n'a jamais eu
une danse que sous emmanuel macron nom
de chien saucisse n'importe quoi là
aussi chômeurs a baissé deux ses 1700
milles reprenant les chiens eux oui mais
alors avec vos chiffres vous savez les
chiffres on leur fait dire tout ce que
l'on veut bien sûr vous avez aujourd'hui
un million sept cent mille chômeurs plus
que du temps au tour de nicolas sarkozy
hier à des résidents quand on est
artisan un chiffre lui fait dire ce que
l'on a à la fin du mois t&c rien d'autre
et c'est la même chose ici dans ce que
l'on a aussi vous avez assez mignon
306 millions sept cent mille chômeurs
c'est ça le bilan de manuel macron et
c'est là dessus vous pouvez dire tout ce
que vous voulez de dire tout va bien que
tout est pour le mieux dans le meilleur
des mondes ce n'est pas vrai ce n'est
pas vrai si se disant état exact en tout
cas madame pécresse devrait être
caracoler en tête pour les projets
qu'elle a été justement vous me donnez
une transition parfaite mon cher pierre
cabaret sondage est là le premier tour
bpt vous n'allez dire c'est que des
chiffres et ce ne sont que des sondages
mais tout de même emmanuel macron moins
trois points 1 sur ce sondage 23%
valérie pécresse 17% à égalité avec
marine le pen ça il ya du changement
j'imagine ça vous fait plaisir charles
pratique
les vaccins on emmerde au maximum les
non-vaccinés ça coûté quelques points
emmanuel macron vous regrettez vous en
tant que le soutien du président ses
propos moi je vais pas commenter les
propos d'un président de la république
du président de la république qui savent
à café sans donner d'interview je reçois
dans ma permanence les personnes qui
sont contre la vaccination j'en avais eu
lundi matin qui m'expose toutes les
raisons d'être contre et je leur réponds
avec toutes les raisons d'être pourrais
je les renvoie sur un très bel article
du monde du 5 janvier dernier sur
justement ce vaccin la rn message et
qu'ils proposent a acquis qui entraîne
vers plus de 2 comment dire nous avons
découvert des choses avec sa découvert
des traitements contre les cancers donc
je crois que il faut aussi répondre sur
la liste nationale soit là on est dans
la petite maison cela se joue sur la
présidence non moi je veux pas revenir
dessus sont pas ceux sont pas les
miennes et je les lui laisse et puis
finalement et bien et certainement c'est
très ennuyeux quand même d'avoir des
personnes qui ont à coeur une telle
mauvaise foi devant cette activation et
des arguments qui n'en sont pas je
l'apprends de samson qu'il s'en porter
un peu vain le mot de la fin pour vous
justement sur ce sondage commandé
delattre lecture la lecture elle est
très simple emmanuel macron non pas le
prison la république est en fait le
candidat faut arrêter de prendre les
gens s'y poser un missile emmanuel
macron les candidats mais il est
toujours président de la république et
que le président de la république dise
qu'ils emmerdent une catégorie des
français et bien il le paye cash trois
points ou moins dans les sondages voilà
je crois que c'est très clair et petit à
petit les gens à un moment donné vont
finir par ouvrir les yeux parce qu'il
commence par se faire ouvrir les
oreilles par des mots qui ne sont pas
les mots qu on attendre d'un président
de la république souvent le second tour
de ce sondage 50 50 c'est la première
sortie
emmanuel macron a déjà été battu dans
certains sondages par valérie pécresse
évidemment aujourd'hui dans ce sondage
là afssa les sondages et y en a beaucoup
dans ce sondage là ils sont à 50-50
c'est à dire que dans la main d'erreurs
ça veut dire dans ce sondage là l'un ou
l'autre peut gagner ce sondage est très
intéressant pourquoi parce qu'il montre
aux français qu'en réalité la seule
personne qui est capable de sortir le
sortant parce qu'évidemment les français
en ont marre des manuels macro et donc
ils veulent sortir le sortant la seule
personne qui est capable de le faire
c'est valérie pécresse et ça ça parle à
tous les électeurs tant de droite que de
gauche d'ailleurs d'ailleurs quand vous
regardez les transferts de voix vous
rendez compte que valérie pécresse sur
ce deuxième tour rassemble rassemble à
droite rassemblent au centre rassemble à
gauche à son beau coup en ile de france
parce qu'elle est très majoritairement
seront ce sondage là en ile-de-france au
deuxième tour est en réalité on a quand
même le sentiment qu'aujourd'hui les
choses sont claires si on veut sortir
emmanuel macron il faut voter valérie
pécresse en tout cas vous êtes souvient
évidemment de valérie pécresse et
l'élection dans moins de trois mois
merci en tout cas charles
avec nous et je rappelle évidemment vous
pouvez nous écrire pour raconter vos
histoires vont faire part de vos
témoignages qu plf
@ rt tv.fr et c'est la fin de cette
émission se retrouvent demain 20 heures
[Musique]